I come to this video playing our rosters
restos the Cyprus all yeah cyprus okay
the Sicilian maybe a classical the soil
never play that so being a bit
adventurous f4 wow yeah I guess why not
I don't know what what is good against
that so let's transpose to some sort of
siphoning and formation or even in and
try to pronounce this correctly failing
as usual but I gave it a try okay what
is he doing with Queen a free and stuff
this is this is not not bad very
aggressive queen of three long castle is
a very aggressive setup Oh is he just
playing Bishop e2 one and now let's see
i am ok trying to give this a fish
ourselves in flare but am I not able to
play dd5 isn't d5 good doing I could
have done that actually move earlier
maybe I should have done that a move
earlier Knight takes e4 was also
interesting of course the sacrifice
okay so I don't mind that nice pawn
structure and he's got some weekend
squares um if I go Knight g4 Bishop g4
should be 554 I'm not sure about this
can I go see five then you might have
see what what is he doing against c5
really Bishop b5 maybe we should be five
if it looks very weird looks very weird
I have I don't know push-up t4c 555 I
can take defy that's not working and to
Bishop b5 mm i can at least I can take
it and place you for at least four for a
good position yeah okay so probably this
is not this is okay all right it's
difficult for him to do something else
besides I mean except Bishop deform now
you cannot really cover it I take it
play default pork for Kim Bishop f2i
Teague and also win material yeah I'm so
c5 yes okay so he's giving away the
piece here okay
but it should it should really be
insufficient am the knight on d4 is
protected and I I even threaten 93 now
okay what about this if I can I go for a
counter-attack directly like with c4 him
c4 he s got queen d 4 but this is a
self-penned naquin d for Queen D for
King age 6 even as possible but he can
take on c4 and okay but I can play ac4 I
can give the check that i can play a
bishop f6 I mean yeah maybe it's this is
a good idea to to to clarify the
situation a bit
24 is really the only move Bishop c4 a
test Bishop c5 check king edge one Queen
edge for this is a direct win for black
so he has to play Queen deform and after
that I was thinking probably but I
probably fish up at six Quincy for maybe
I can play Bishop a six then Queen takes
Bishop t4 check King edge one this is
possible Queen edge fire this is a win
that's funny so it is not going for it
so okay the check yeah yes God he's got
no check so age three and then queen bee
three with this this typical made age
three Queens III takes on g4 queen edge
for made something something similar
could have happened in the other line i
believe mmm yeah that's the same thing
in the other line
yeah he really only has 83 I camp got to
move see I resigning or a 3 i'm
overlooking something very soon like
resign no not really yeah the maid the
maid is coming with this checkmate and
the alternative here was that after
takes see form which is such a strong
and if he is giving the check which
looks a bit check more interesting i
have this this and this this is what i
was briefly mentioning but then he
played to play the other stuff that idea
is that here we have exactly the same
mating business his queen is offside on
a six and of course if he is not taking
on on see form or let's say if he's not
taking the bishop then I'm just grabbing
another rook on f1 end and win so the
real problem was that he had after this
and this c5 yeah he I mean he is not in
good shape but he can still try to fight
with Bishop f2 I guess keeping keeping
material on the board at the at least
yeah it's also a problem at this this is
also terrible and I'm winning winning
this yeah now maybe he can try to to do
this but check this is what the computer
is giving that's quite convincing yeah
with c4 check being the idea why this
really white is really uncoordinated
with this open king and and stuff yeah
it was wasn't a good idea to allow this
this is a 5 this d5 business and in
addition to take here probably and not
not helping as well but he could have
went here or two
III and just play this of course this f4
move oops this f4 move it does not
really belong here because it weakens so
many squares but okay white white can
still play play this on without having
lost any substantial material okay
thanks for watching